this is the Dave Ramsey show we're
talking with Alex in Pittsburgh makes
30,000 a year his friend gave him a
Mustang from church but free as a gift
he's thinking he wants to sell it in
order to pay some bills and the phrase
was I can't financially afford two cars
and so that's how far we got in the
discussion is that a fair summary of
what you told me so far sir yeah okay so
well the first thing is if you're
married
what is the Mustang Worth says that it's
right around 2000 something like that
but in my area I could get more for it
okay all right and how much debt do you
have sir right around fifty thousand
right now on what student loans my
wife's car and then credit card that
that's how much do you owe in your
wife's car my wife's car is I'm not even
sure right off and I think it's right
around five thousand something like that
okay
so is the majority of the fifty thousand
student loan debt then yeah yeah it's
like 36 something like that and what do
you do for a living sir I'm a chimney
sweep okay and how old are you 24 okay
all right well you're just kind of
getting started not only in your career
but obviously both of you have run up a
bunch of student loan debt or one of you
has I'm assuming she's not working
outside the home
I see the waitress okay and who has the
degree he does in what surgical
technology and why is she not in that
field right now there's no jobs hiring
and she's looking to go back for her
nursing degree yeah well that won't be
happening anytime soon you guys are
pretty broke we gotta we gotta get some
student loan debt paid off well I I long
has she been out of school Oh year-round
a year okay well here's the thing $2,000
really doesn't solve any of your
problems you got a lot bigger problems
than $2,000 would
agree with that oh yeah okay it would
help a little and the good news about a
$2,000 car is it's not gonna take a lot
of insurance to cover it and it might be
that she could work more if you had two
cars I mean I I have a work vehicle that
I might drive where I need to know I
realize that oh so this isn't
essentially a third car yeah basically
basically it'd be a second personal
vehicle and so what is your income my
income is right around 21 to 22
something like that okay and you own the
business are you working for someone now
I'm just working for somebody okay well
if you want to give the car or sell the
car that's fine the only thing you would
do is I just treat the way you answer
ethics questions is you treat other
people like you want to be treated it's
a golden rule right and so if you gave
someone a car or would you want them to
do I'll tell you what I'd want you to do
if I gave you a car I was giving you a
car for transportation because I was
trying to be a blessing to you but if
you came back to me and said look I've
got this work truck my wife's already
got a car I got a bunch of dead I'm
trying to pay off would you be offended
if I sold it and used the you use the
proceeds to pay towards my debt if
that's offensive to you and you want me
to donate the car to someone else I'll
do that I just don't I mean you've been
kind to me and generous to me and I
don't want to do something that's wrong
in your eyes so what would you like for
me to do and just talk to them over a
cup of coffee if the roles were reversed
you'd probably like somebody to do that
with you right yeah definitely and so
that's a good way to handle it and then
if you want to sell it and put it
towards the debt you can okay okay then
let me just tell you that's a tiny bit
of your situation the biggest the
biggest problem you all are facing is
your income epidemic we've got to do
some stuff to get her into her career
field as soon as possible and someone in
the Pittsburgh area is hiring for
something and pulled more than
waitressing with the job that she's
going with the int with the degree that
she's got and so I really want you guys
to scratch and claw and keep pushing and
finding
looking and asking everybody you know in
the medical field what you can do and
here's the thing she can do I mean if
she's waitressing she's probably doing a
lot of it at night then she could go
during the day where they're doing
surgical tech stuff and just say hey I
will volunteer here for two weeks to
show you how good I am and just get in
there and be the nicest person in the
world the most helpful person in the
world and dad-blamed they won't turn
around hire you sometimes you can get
your foot your foot in the door doing
that stuff and you can show off your
skills show off what you learn to
getting the degree and let her get her
income up because you know she can step
in there and go to 40 or so then your
household income completely changes and
then your career continues to unfold and
get better and better now we've got some
some money to fight this debt monster
with right now you guys are just trying
to keep the lights on right and so that
that's what I want you to do now have
you guys been through Financial Peace
University yet yeah yeah we actually
just went through it about two months
ago we finished up perfect okay well I'm
glad and you know it's life time so you
can go back if you need to if you need a
refresher you're going along I was going
to give it to you but you've already
been through it so that's awesome
hey man thank you for the call and I
appreciate you being in our listening
audience if I can help you any further
Alex you call me anytime hey you guys
Rachael Cruz here hope you're enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show and did you know
that I have my very own YouTube channel
yes that's right kind of better
save room to channel I'll tell them
myself that I'm kidding I'm panic
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you